foreign
people welcome to an episode honest
trailer commentaries coming to you live
in studio just hang with the boys today
me and Lon talking home alone too I got
all I got a holiday festive because of
Home Alone 2 this week I thought maybe
we would we would have a special yeah
and below the desk I'm only wearing
Christmas stockings free
um so we're doing that mistletoe so
we're doing a comfort uh film classic so
get cozy we're talking Home Alone 2
we'll talk about our thoughts behind the
film to the extent that we have them I
don't have many it's nice uh we'll watch
it on Australia together start and stop
as we go we have some deleted scenes
this week we've got some uh q a so put
your questions in the chat and we'll
respond to them or just comments um on
our sweaters and then uh we'll tease you
with next week's honest trailer
um it's gonna be a good one wow it's
gonna be a slog uh a real test of of
moral and physical fortitude yeah um
yeah don't eat during it that's
something I learned anyways we're enough
about next week uh let's talk about this
week Home Alone 2 lost in New York
uh it's it's comforting it's I prefer
this to the original Home Alone what
yeah that's crazy oh we gotta fight all
right movie fight
versus Home Alone one make your case for
Home Alone one what I just I mean this
is we don't get a lot of Comedy sequels
anymore like I think that it's kind of
almost like a lost start like like how
often does a cop a new you know there's
Legacy sequels like there's the
Ghostbusters you know whatever they show
afterlife but uh but not a lot of like
well this comedy did really well in
theaters we're gonna make another one
like hangover I feel like was like the
last time this happened really yeah uh
sure and but I would say that with
enough distance from them like
Ghostbusters one and two I came to
Ghostbusters late in life right and I'm
like oh Ghostbusters 2 is really funny
because I'm not seeing it directly on
the heels of Ghostbusters one where all
the jokes are old because they're just
repeating this I still like those
Brothers there's two more than most but
I right but I think you're getting it
the the meat of what I was gonna say
which is the the thing with comedy
sequels they kind of inherently makes
them disappointing is also true of Home
Alone 2 which is it's just really really
funny the second time it's just really
redoing the best bits from the first one
and you we saw those already so the the
shock the thrill of seeing them the
first time is gone and by this point
especially by the time I'd seen Home
Alone 2 I'd already been re-watching
home alone one so that it's like double
the the impact was blunted twice because
I know not only had I already seen the
jokes before in home alone but already
like half memorized Home Alone one well
to me what what the the Special Sauce
that makes the Home Alone the first two
work is the um
wish fulfillment escapism of having a uh
being a kid on vacation all by yourself
whether that's at home or as all the
best rom-coms do in another uh place
called New York City which is a
character in and of itself
uh and I do think that they of the of
the movies that are like schmaltzy New
York City greatest place in the world I
think this is one of the best ones being
like Oh man The Plaza Hotel uh being at
that toy store yeah but that sort of
thing and having a limo and a cheese
pizza like I find that more appealing
than
um being in your house
it's more fun to me to watch I if I if
you were gonna say you can recreate one
of the two Home Alone films as a
personal experience sure and as a viewer
to walk to New York more fun and staying
in a hotel what have you uh but I mean I
as a movie I think the first one clearly
also just look at the the quality of
cameos Home Alone one John Candy Home
Alone sure Donald J Trump Home Alone 2
Tim Curry Home Alone one guy with shovel
Trump outweighs all all Home Alone one
Cameo he's a local businessman at this
point you can't predict the future owner
of the play that's his it's his hotel
that's why he's asking him directions
anyway I I don't know I mean uh the
other thing I was gonna say about FAO
Schwartz is like if you brought it up as
a kid the 80s the 80s were full of FAO
Schwartz propaganda aimed at children
big is also that very famous scene where
they're playing the the chopsticks on
the bigger heart and soul yeah on the
big dancing keyboard that's also said in
FAO Schwarz it led me as a kid to
believe FAO Schwartz was going to be
like this magical like next level winter
wonderland for children and then you go
there and it's just a toy I thought it
was pretty incredible I I made a
pilgrimage there when I was at visited
New York because it thought it was
amazing they sold it to us as a kid in
the 80s you really thought FAO Schwartz
was going to be like the be-all end-all
the greatest toy store and then it's
like it's fine but you know what does
and Still Remains the best part of New
York City that all the locals will uh
tell you about if you really get him
honest is uh the m m store in Times
Square that's true everybody does love
the Eminence that is true it's a local
truly what makes it the greatest city in
the world yes it's true like that's it's
mostly locals really like not a lot of
tourists know about it it's mostly just
an Insider thing yeah if you hear them
talking about the the msta M Stow
neighborhood yeah that's what they're
doing it's everything they say is in
reference to the m m store in Times
Square yeah well there's that really hit
neighborhood Dumbo that's down under the
m m store yeah that's where that comes
from that's so good you can get them in
every color folks uh let's watch the uh
for Home Alone 2. lost to New York
from the director of Harry Potter back
when that meant something and a massive
child star it turned out pretty normal
by child star standards and since we are
bound to this planet
comes the 30th anniversary of the rare
holiday sequel that isn't terrible
unnecessary
all about Christmas or completely off
the rails hold tightly to my belt but we
are going to journey through the air and
circle the world weird
so I asked uh Joe
um Joe Starr is a uh Rankin and bass uh
expert
um so I texted him for a few like what's
the weirdest ranking Ambassador how
weird does it get he sent me a couple
Clips uh neither of which was that one
because they they're like the opening
credit sequence of that film
oh my god
um the opening sequence for uh The Life
and Adventures of Santa Claus is like a
it's like a like a like the nightmare
sequence from the Snyder cut but they're
introducing various like not even
Christmas themed gods and Immortals but
just different elves with weird names as
they like make their entrance and then
there's a Gregorian chant going on in
the background going immortality
and it took a little too long to play
out but wow I um I was he did not
disappoint there was a there was like
it's such a long weird
genre like mst3k Mystery Science Theater
every Christmas they used to do like
double features of these movies like
movies that were gonna like we're gonna
make up a mythology around oh and they
did like there's that new one like Klaus
uh on Netflix that's pretty good they
they do it too but it actually kind of
works and it's like a thoughtful sort of
fun mythology but in the 70s and 80s
it's like the 60s there were so many and
they were all like really weird and kind
of half thought out like Dark Fantasy
Santa Claus Origins it's very like Dark
Crystal yeah
um and a lot of puppeteering and a lot
of like uh Klaus from the numenor tribes
yeah it's always like a clan of elves
and it was like once a year they would
give each other um you know gifts and
mementos Santa was raised by a lion yeah
it's always and it was always weird and
kind of creepy and it's like no no kids
don't want to hear they just like Santa
yeah what's this year's uh entry in the
Santa Mythos this was all we had folks
yeah
um so yeah thank you I guess it's gonna
be Tim Allen in the Santa Clauses is
this year's thing well and now every
time Santa has to kill people now like
there's the David Harbor yeah everybody
wants and then like or the rock it's
like red one everybody wants to do the
night the reindeer died now that the
movie from Scrooge differently Mages uh
let's keep playing but Ryan why don't
you bring the dog on camera just so
people can see there's a dog there's a
puppy yeah there's a lot of there's some
there's something
oh nice yeah well making their honest
trailer commentary debut this is Keiko
yeah Keiko was on andors
she hates plot holes and Mary Sue's yeah
and Brie Larson yeah um well uh she's
welcome on anytime I'm just I can't stop
looking at the dog but just play come on
too while we stare at the dog
[Music]
oh she left it's Christmas time once
again for the McAlister's Buzz is still
a bully
Fuller is a whiz kid you sleep on the
third floor yeah with me she's
scratching her leg mom's telepathic I
have that feeling
tonight
and the other two of our background
gingers who contribute nothing at all to
the story but while big p doesn't even
get a line laugh along with little Kevin
while he talks to himself for two hours
those guys my family's in Florida and
I'm in New York last hotel New York's
most exciting Hotel it's luxurious and
special Merry Christmas kids this is the
greatest action can mess with a lot of
things
you're back from Paris I'll drop in on
them there's nobody else in the room Kev
Uncle Frank really messed you up huh you
know what they're going to call you in
France don't you huh no yank it's a
pause
uh I stumbled across
um I guess there's much like a Uncle
Charlie from Willy Wonka what's his name
uh the or Grandpa Grandpa Joe much like
Grandpa Joe in that there's like online
hate communities dedicated to
um you know calling out Uncle Frank I
mean he sucks he does suck yeah he
definitely sucks and that led me to find
the uh the deleted scene
pants is Kevin yeah
um yeah he's he's a freeloader we knew
that
um but like he's already uh being
bullied by the rest of his by his
siblings but then Uncle Frank is like an
adult who should know better who joins
in there's a there's a weird when you're
a kid I think you just accept some stuff
in movies and especially with like big
fat like I did not have a big family it
was just me my parents and my younger
brother so I accepted in movies that
like well big families were really
different from mine so I just like
whatever that that's what their family
is like yeah but when you go back to
home alone and Home Alone two years
later there it's a weird fact like the
mcallisters are an odd Bunch like we
don't really get how why they're so rich
or what the circumstance is why this
family like how they happen to just be
living that way like we don't like we
don't know what his job is it's not
built into the money Factory yeah he's
just like he just like Dad has a really
fancy job but there's like there's so
many of them and it is almost like John
heard and Uncle Frank are like too old
to be the dad and the uncle of all these
like small kids I think the uncle yes
plays looks older yeah like Uncle Fred
feels like he's in his what 50s like why
is he they've got little kids he's this
yeah he's an uncle to these little kids
like the whole thing is there's just
like an oddness dude an unspoken oddness
to it and like a Brady Bunch situation
do they all live together right exactly
or is this just for Christmas all of
this and there's no context we just come
in and it's like here's this crazy
family and they gotta get to the airport
yeah yeah he sucks uh they all they all
gang up um the the mom even does is not
I I feel does not do enough to protect
Kevin from The Vicious bullying that
he's a victim of everybody else and it
doesn't even
if you like like well they're a big
family and they love each other but they
pick on each other it really feels like
this these evil people have just
descended on his home and they're
wrecking his life yeah so I
everything okay oh the dog is no she
just peed well you know so did I so uh
peeing your pants is cool
all right let's keep let's keep going
when Kevin gets shunned by his own
family again and stuck up in the Atticus
punishment again he'll be all alone
thanks to a last second travel mix up
again
lies to adults again you think I'd be
here alone
I don't think so kid going into a hotel
making a reservation I don't think so
make use of convenient movie dialogue
again I'm gonna give you to the count of
ten I'm gonna give you to the count of
three get stopped by two burglars again
build up a library trap house again get
build a muscarial stranger again yada
yada hey come on it all worked out great
the first time why not just try it again
just don't try it again again Home Alone
3 or again again Home Alone taking back
the house again again again again Home
Alone the Holiday Heist and definitely
not again again again again that would
just be stupid home sweet home alone
pause uh how many of those have you seen
uh I have seen home sweet home alone I
have not seen the new three four or five
but I saw that I saw the Rob Delaney
Ellie Camp that's like inexplicably
British
hey inexplicable is a good word okay I
mean I don't like I I I get it because
it's home alone and it's like one of the
biggest brand names in movie Dome and
you want to keep making things that are
called Home Alone yeah totally get it
from a money perspective but it's so
specific like it's such a specific thing
that it is yeah it tells you that it
just shows the importance of casting and
performance because it's Macaulay Culkin
and Joe Pesci and Daniel Stern I think
that make the movie work yeah I mean I'm
almost tempted to say you could get away
from kid vacation left by themselves
well then you just have like Panic Room
yeah I mean basically I think like the
the traps get kid setting traps to hurt
evil adults to me that's almost the
heart and soul of it yeah more than
anything else like maybe if you kept
holiday like it's around Christmas time
and a child is is injuring adults that
you don't feel bad for it's Arbor Day
and they're kind of shut down they're
gonna burn down the boy scout camp like
now you're talking like I almost feel
like it's malleable enough that you
could do stuff like that like well
what's the what's the Thanksgiving one
not a Christmas one like what's the
what's the whole family's setting traps
together is there an Easter version of
this yeah they're in a meadow and each
egg is filled with arsenic I don't know
what is what do you do for each turn I
don't know it's an eve it's a it's a
priest now who's coming after them yeah
um I just know Home Alone 3 a big part
for uh black widows Carl Johansson ah
well there yeah look at that yeah that's
all I remember around for a long time
before she got famous in action world
had to do that stuff yeah good for it
all right keep going
B visits screenwriter John Hughes happy
plays the white side of Chicago then
take advantage of 1992's lacks airport
security are you sure your family's on
this flight yeah to visit New York City
scale the mighty Twin Towers experience
the magic of Central Park watch it kid
and potentially get shot on Fifth Avenue
down the hall and to the left just don't
cross the staff at the Plaza Hotel these
grinches are out to ruin Christmas by
refusing to let a child fake his
identity this is Peter McAllister
got it
and step them on tips and there's plenty
more where that came from grown-ups
doing your jobs yeah hope you get
smacked in the face and think you're
being shot to death
so pause
um I didn't really dive into it but it I
I noted how many John hughesisms there
are in this like of a a kid breaking the
fourth wall all of Ferris Bueller sure
the city of Chicago
um unhelpful uh like Transportation
bureaucracy like Planes Trains and
Automobiles and this one of just never
getting help from like an airline
counter uh keeps coming up he's got his
moves oh yeah I mean there was there was
like this whole the kind of writing that
they used to call like you you would get
called a humorist you know like Dave
Barry yeah I'm a bomb bag or it's like
that that very like observational folksy
kind of Garrison Keeler type humor and
like yeah I feel like that's what John
Hughes was very good I like like that
kind of humor with just enough Edge to
feel like it was relatable and like to
feel like you know it felt natural yeah
but it was is like that very like broad
Midwestern folksie like we airports am I
right folks you know and it's like that
level of comedy and he would but he was
I mean this in a in a complimentary way
like he was so good at that I much
prefer that to being like we're in a
Christmas movie folks wink wink right
exactly he's right behind me isn't he
it's not that it's that very relatable
like listen we all the Christmas is
tough right but it's your only chance to
see your family so we all put up with it
and it's like that it's hard to do that
that voice and they hit that so without
going like full Hall Mark right without
being just utter Schmaltz yeah and like
to hit that to hit that line uh and you
know like he that's what he's doing like
so well over like Uncle Buck is a great
example of like it should be so hokey
what he's doing in that movie but
there's just enough Edge he and John
Candy just kind of nail that back yeah
yeah that he's dead right yeah not John
Candy obviously John Candy have sadly
left yeah that's bummer all right keep
going
return to the franchise that mixes
luxurious escapism for kids with
torturing criminals to death also for
kids
and while the cursing remains PG
food
the violence is rated X as in Kevin
murders them 10 different ways
[Music]
so pause he might just have third degree
burns all over his scalp from that I
don't know if that would it's a the
toilet is full of kerosene and he dunks
it he dunks a flaming head
probably burn through a few top layers
yeah it'd be full Red Skull after that
yeah but we did a video in uh 10 years
ago almost 10 years ago now that was we
got a doctor this is before all the real
Doctor looks at blah blah we counted up
all the times that
um they would have died in Home Alone
it's the paint cans to the face part
that's particularly brutal yeah yeah the
thing is that well and each brick the
doctor said would be a death I uh you
know don't always listen to your
doctor's advice kids because I look I
re-watched that video and thought some
of them were a little questionable I
thought he was a little generous with
the deaths
um we we ended up at like a number I
think two or three fewer deaths yeah
than the doctor said they would but
still over 10 murders he wants to be
cautious he doesn't want to encourage
you but like this wouldn't kill you so
try it before do it you'll be fine
you'll be fine I bet you'd be fine uh
there you go all right continue the
death
that's enough Kevin
that would kill you yeah this is really
brutal oh Heaven stop
three stories
four I guess
please they're already dead and then
those are full cans of varnish yeah yeah
did you guys give up have you had enough
pain yes Mercy
they're also they're trying to steal you
know like
like 50 Grand worth of stuff they're not
trying it's not like the the a once in a
lifetime score it's like a house or they
just need enough money to get to Mexico
or something yeah this one is like a
hotel room or something they're trying
like like I don't think they're the best
Bandits I'm starting to think these guys
are actually uh Goofs it's not even like
an Ocean's uh 12 level score it's just
like a house well I find funny about
this is that
um of course Kevin is going to defend
his home from a from an invasion right
and this one he is seeking out oh yeah
he is actually actively going after
criminals this is Revenge of Revenge
yeah I'm gonna kill them so they can
never kill again that kind of thing all
right good for him uh is it just
vigilante justice now so cuddle up for a
sequel to the film about standing your
ground hello that's now about leaving
your home to dish out vigilante justice
across state lines
in this celebration of every child's
most deeply held Christmas fantasies
having a talk boy eating pizza and
limousine on your way to a toy store and
telling Rob Schneider to [ __ ] off nice
family
story
terrorist viewers week off oh so I'm
funny now huh what's the funny about me
huh oh it's all again hit the head and
falling over stuff yeah right that's
pretty funny
boy we need to talk about
succession
Pennywise pound foolish
the Schneider cut bird woman or the
unexpected virtue of homelessness and
Jeffrey it's your friend Donald you know
those kids are looking for get all out
of this
one too It Takes Manhattan
all right everyone let's dig it
[Music]
they finally tracked down their son and
he immediately sneaks off on his own to
see the pigeon lady
will someone put a leash on this kid
yeah that one's on them yeah
um there you go I look there you can't
really over analyze this one it's the
it's they just did Home Alone Again Home
Alone what if another what if another
Home Alone what if we did that again you
liked it uh but I personally just I just
I just enjoyed the the palette swap that
they did you know like like for whatever
reason I prefer
um you know Sub-Zero to scorpion that's
fine I I mean I guess I was old enough
to like be a little cynical by that but
like I I wanted to see a new movie and
it just it does it does feel like hey
home alone but but another one well they
kept doing it yeah and doing it and
doing it well
um all right let's see the deleted scene
pretty well you know all right
foreign
Little Mac
scream Queens Apple Mac The Good Son
Goodfellas versus good feathers city
sticker
oh here to O'Hara a bad mom's Christmas
[ __ ] squeak Roman Holiday
Pennywise oranges
one room
scary bird and we love getting lost in
New York don't we folks
we need to talk about Kevin
bright Tike big city
[Music]
man McAllister's never learned from
their mistakes huh they don't even move
the stupid lawn jockey
there you go um there was also a delete
say I don't know it didn't make it into
the Montage where we talked about how
this movie inexplicably hates the French
I mean I guess that is just like an
American Comfort classic yeah the French
suck that it's exactly that that like
exactly what we were saying about John
Hughes where it's like he loves a good
trophy folksie like nothing nothing more
middle American than hating on the oh
the French are so rude because that's
also like like if you go back uh
vacation is like the vacation movies are
full of that kind of level of humor as
well like well Ryan is literally rolling
on the ground with a puppy may I achieve
that level of Joy at some point right
like that's the like British people
super super they're the top polite and
snooty they have French people rude
uh Florida sucks you hear that right
yeah that was also a big part of the
movie is how bad Florida is uh
all right uh where are we at we uh thank
you so much for watching like subscribe
hit the Bell Ringling a ding dong
um we'll make more things they'll be
right here so keep watching them here
are your questions we'd love to please
Adam Holbert uh and is this one of the
few movies where pain and suffering from
killer traps is hilarious I mean have
you ever seen like Looney Tunes like the
Road Runner this is the foundational uh
part of humor is people hurting
themselves it is in a it's in a strong
tradition going back to I mean the
silent comedy era obviously like Laurel
and Hardy and Buster Keaton and Charlie
Chaplin like I think that this is
directly a descendant of that stuff yeah
uh scare shark ass if you had to make a
home alone sequel to reboot how would
you do it in a way that's fresh I think
we were on to that yeah well I like I
really like the the different holiday
idea like it doesn't have to always be
Christmas it could be you know people go
on vacation a bunch day like it's spring
summer break yeah summer break how about
like a booby trap water park
they bring he actually comes on the
vacation this time and she's not home
alone yeah he's home with these these
away with family interesting maybe the
maybe he's uh trying to kill the
burglars at their home
he's taking the fight to them
like a horror movie one from the
burglar's perspective from the burglar's
perspective
that's right yeah where the Harry Harry
and Marv are maybe trapped in in
solitary confinement and there's Kevin
is working his way through different
cell blocks to kill you ever see brawl
in cell block 99.
uh and speaking of which we'll end with
this gym 1s with all the Legacy sequels
we're getting like Christmas Story and
Top Gun do you think we'll finally get a
true Home Alone 3 with adult Macaulay
Culkin yeah uh and his family I think we
could I mean macaulay's he's on red
letter media he seems like a great dude
he's yeah Macaulay Culkin getting him to
do it probably I think Daniel Stern
would be is down um Joe Pesci I don't
know is he retired yeah he came out of
retirement to do the Irishman so I think
if you get De Niro and Scorsese involved
somehow I think he would come along yeah
um and then you know you got Kieran
Culkin who's like Prestige TV that's
right Golden Child now you definitely
have Fuller
um make a make a cameo sure like maybe
you know you know if Patrick doesn't
want to come back Brian Cox could fill
in yes I think he could be our Mar yes
that was great Harry he's Harry
um all right and then let's actually do
this one with Reynard City update
Channel if you were alone in your home
with I guess two people not just if
you're alone in your home uh with
Robert's trying to happen okay what
would you do
if you knew that they were coming at 9
00
pm
and for whatever reason you can't call
the cops I mean I like I don't have
anything the the effort it would take me
to create traps to repel them it would
be more valuable to me than anything
they could take they can they can have
my they can take whatever yeah I would
just leave like yeah if they really want
my long car wide Criterion box set they
can have it I have a Eric Estrada uh
signed Sea Lab uh photo yeah that I
would sell that I would take and I put
that in my coat and I would leave yeah
they can watch my Bergman oh and I guess
my wife and child yeah
God more valuable yeah
um all right uh this has been uh lovely
what it's a lovely get-together what a
treat let's do it again next week um we
should but it's going to be a little bit
more Grim a little bit harder to get
through uh we're gonna have to rely on
our brothers it's gritty
um we're gonna have to do everything it
takes uh to find a special little boy in
a very bad place not a little bold well
he's he's he looks like a little he has
his teeth are too white is yeah
um he's not very naive yeah in some ways
but you know what maybe that's what it's
all about at the end of the day
um I know we're being vague but uh we're
gonna we're gonna earn this we're gonna
earn this one yeah uh we'll see ya next
week go vote uh if it's early enough or
late yeah if you're watching this on
Tuesday uh go vote and don't listen to
Katy Perry do what Katy Perry if he
doesn't know what she's talking about oh
look dog all right see you then bye-bye
foreign
[Music]